thank you at first I express my
gratitude for the warm Hospitality to
his Royal Highness Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman to the entire people of Saudi
Arabia and the city of jadan which is
hosting this
meeting I hope that most of us are here
for the sake of peace and justice
dear participants dear participants of
the summit today is the
450 SD of the full-scale war waged
against us by Russian Invaders and I'm
also sure all your Nations will
understand the main call I want to live
here in German a noble call to all of
you to help protect our people including
Ukrainian Muslim Community for centuries
the Crimea Tatar have been and should
remain
an integral and strong part of the
Muslim Community of the world but
Premiere was the first to suffer from
the Russian occupation and until now
most of those who are subjected to
repression
in the occupied Crimea are Muslims we
already have a positive experience with
Saudi Arabia regarding
the release of our people captured by
Russia we can expand this experience and
even
if there are people here at the summit
who have a different view on the war on
on our land calling it a conflict I'm
sure that we can all be United in saving
people from the cages of Russian prisons
unfortunately and there are some in the
world and here among you who turn a
blind eye to those cages and illegal
annexations
the idea